Colonel: What the hell is going on?
Where's Celine?
George: She's gone, and so is everyone else.
Detective: Wait a minute, where the hell do you think you're going?!
George: Away from here! This place is cursed!
If you'd half a brain, you'd all do the same.
Colonel: Don't walk away from me! Where's Celine? Where's Damien!?
Chef: I've spent 25 years cooking for these uppity fucks. I'm not about to die for 'em! I quit!
Bitch!
Butler: I know things seem far beyond your control right now, but such that it is for all of us here.
I shall take my leave, and I implore you to do the same.
Colonel I won't let my friends die in this godforsaken house!
And if you all are too much of a coward to do the same, you had best leave before I kill you myself!
Detective: Now you hold on a second, I've got more questions–
Colonel: Get your hands off me!
Detective: What the hell is going on here?!
Butler: I know he's in pain and I know you might be, too...
But we need to leave this place.
There's only death here now.
[music fades, distorts, sound of a heartbeat echos]
(whispered) Hey!
(whispered) Help!
(distorted) Madness!
(distorted) You wanna talk about madness?
(distorted) Madness is stealing your best friend's wife.
(distorted) Be careful.
(distorted) Now this evening, it's not all about the poker; it's not all about me.
(distorted) Can't we resolve this amicably?
(distorted) Life needs a bit of madness, eh, chap?
(distorted) Good to let the beast out every once in a while, eh, old friend?
(distorted) I'm not gonna just sit around and let you drag my partner off to their very likely death!
(distorted) I thought I told you to stay out of my kitchen!
(distorted) A domain of evil this is... but in we must go.
(distorted) You first...
[music returns to normal, heartbeat remains]
Colonel: There you are! I've been meaning to ask you some questions–
What is this?
The detective's been keeping tabs on us?
The detective's been keeping tabs on me.
And Celine!
He's the one who orchestrated ALL of this!
He DID this!
Detective!
DETECTIVE!
Where is he?
He took them from me...
He took my friends from ME.
He took...Celine.
He took Damien!
Where is he?
WHERE IS HE?!
DETECTIVE! Are you hiding him from me?!
He can't hide forever. GET OUT OF MY WAY!
DETECTIVE!
Detective: You'd better choose your next words carefully, Colonel.
Colonel: Only my friends get to call me by that name, and you, sir, are NO friend of mine!
Detective: Well, you're one to talk about friends, you MURDERER! [thunder]
Colonel: I didn't kill anybody! This is MADNESS!
Detective: Oh, you wanna talk about madness? Madness is stealing your best friend's wife.
Madness is squeezing him for cash to fund your own sick sexual exploits with that very woman–
Colonel: SHUT UP!
Detective: Madness is plotting the death of your childhood friend because you can't handle the–
[gunshot, thunder]
[intense, droning music picks up]
[Gunshot]
[Colonel, distorted] It was an accident!
[crash]
[slow, distorted] I swear...
[Music begins, crescendos]
[Heartbeat begins]
[Distorted voice] Body: It's not fair, isn't it?
[All sounds are echoed]
Damien: He took everything from us. He trapped us in here with this broken shell and no way out.
Celine: It's true. This whole time I thought it was the house but...
I never thought he'd fall this far.
Damien: And we played right into his hands.
He'd been planning this for years and now that son-of-a-bitch is out there walking around in MY body–
Celine: Damien, we CAN'T do this right now.
Look, I know you have questions and I can't answer everything right now.
Just know that Mark took everything from us from his twisted quest of vengeance.
But death does not mean the same thing here.
Damien: What Celine means by that is..
This doesn't have to be the end.
You're trapped in here just the same as us, but your body...
Broken as it may be, it's still out there.
Celine: Mark's not the only one that can use this place to his benefit.
The same way that I brought you here, is the same way that I can send you back.
Damien: But you can't survive on your own.
You're dead, after all. The Colonel saw to that.
Celine You can't blame him. Honestly, he's a good man.
But he's dangerous now.
Damien: I know this all sounds crazy.
Honestly, I don't know what the fuck is going on.
But I know that I trust Celine.
And if you trust us...
Just...let me in. [flicker] We can fix this. Together.
Celine: I won't force this on you. You have a choice here.
Just know this is the only way that you can escape.
Just relax.
Damien: This'll work. I promise.
[rumbling thunder]
[creaking noises]
Colonel: Oh no! No! It's okay.
I-I thought you were dead.
I-I-I mean, of course you're not dead! You're not—how could you be dead?
I mean, I-I wouldn't have killed you. I-I didn't kill you.
[Soft piano music starts]
I mean, of cour–I-I...
Of course!
I didn't kill anybody!
[laughter] I didn't-
It was all a joke!
Of course, it was all a joke!
Were you in on this!?
Did Damien put you up to this? Of course he did!
Damien, where are you, you rapscallion?
Where are you?
Celine?
Ah, it's time to come out now!
AH!
It was good, it was good! You almost had me!
[Slight warped] Ha! Ha, ha...Celine?
[Crackling, static noises]
[Slight static persists]
[Music ends on unfinished chord, fades out]
[loud static]
[short beep]
[coughing]
Detective: Colonel...
If you can hear this...
You better run.
[Radio turns off]